what is one of the most versatile
communication tools everyone should have
in their toolkits the answer is
asking questions
i think questions are the swiss army
knife of communication a well-timed
question can accomplish myriad
communication tasks from building trust
and understanding to fostering
engagement and calming your nerves
through asking good questions you can
become a more connected and authentic
communicator
my name is matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today i am super excited to have deborah
schifrin here
deborah is a lecturer at stanford
graduate school of business where she
teaches two mba courses she co-created
spontaneous management
and creativity in the business ecosystem
prior to joining stanford debra spent a
decade as a national public radio
reporter producer and director
welcome deborah i love collaborating
with you and i look forward to our chat
me too let's get started
why questions what do they do for us
there's a range of goals and purposes we
have for asking questions
of course a big one is getting
information
matt what time is it
uh it's a little bit before noon
actually
so that's how that works i needed
information i asked matt and i got the
information i needed
but the second one is building
relationships so you want to use it to
build relationships you ask people
questions you get to know about them and
they get to know about you
and then there's other goals you can use
in the workplace you can ask questions
to generate ideas and foster creativity
then of course with the darker goals
like interrogate or intimidate or avoid
responsibility
i think i'll take one matt if it's okay
and break it down a little bit oh
absolutely i'd love to hear more so one
of the big ones i mentioned was building
relationships
so if you're asking questions
you're signaling to the other person
that you value them you're taking time
to listen to their answers
you're telling them that their answers
matter and they matter
and the other one that i think is really
important is
the type of question that comes with
coaching or mentoring people and a lot
of people are mentors a lot of leaders
are mentors to
younger people coming up in the
organization
for me i use it mostly in my coaching
practice
and i'll give you two examples which i
love
imagine i'm talking to someone and they
are deciding whether to take a job offer
they'll be talking and they'll be
weighing the pros and cons right
and then i'll stop them and i'll say
what do you want
and it's sort of a disruptive question
it breaks the back and forth between the
tactical decisions and it just takes
things up to another level a second one
is say someone is telling me they're
feeling inadequate when i hear that a
couple of times i will say
how is feeling inadequate serving you
and what is it costing you
and it really makes people stop and
think about it how is it supporting me
and how is it harming me and it makes
people either take action to change it
or change their mindset
i see you know a key takeaway i i had
from what you just said is it's
it's not just the question you ask but
it's the willingness to actually ask the
question in the first place and then
listen to the answer that's what can
really help disrupt the conversation or
show that you you really are concerned
with the person and want to foster that
connection is that right yes absolutely
and you have to have some sort of trust
built up so this isn't a question you're
not going to meet someone for the first
time and say matt what do you want
but if you have a relationship with
someone of some sort where there's some
trust then you can start using those
questions
clearly questions can help us achieve
many ends that are positive and
pro-social but you did mention that
goals were not always as friendly such
as intimidation and avoiding
responsibility can you talk more about
these
yes i can i'll mention interrogating so
this is another way to get information i
suppose but you're doing it in a very
unpleasant way you might try to trap
someone into making a mistake or doing a
gotcha question and so that's not very
pleasant
people can use questions to intimidate
and a lot of times that has to do with
power dynamics so they may want to use a
question to increase their power dynamic
or take advantage of a power dynamic
that already exists
and a third one is
avoiding responsibility
so
this brings me back to my improv
training days many years ago when i was
learning
and
we are told as improvisers not to ask
questions on stage
and it may seem counter intuitive
but the reason is say you and i are in a
scene and we're both creating it
together there's no script so we're
going back and forth and building
something and if i keep asking you
questions
you have to do all the work to come up
with all the ideas you don't want to do
that you want to share the burden
and there's an example that i think most
people can relate to
so matt say we were going to go to a
movie and we were
trying to figure out where to go to
dinner let's say there's like five of us
and someone will say hey
where do you want to go for dinner
and the next person will say i don't
know where do you want to go for dinner
and that could go to all five people you
i think you're describing my entire
teenage years i think that's what we did
every friday and saturday night believe
me it so happens to me now i'm in san
francisco and there's so many options
but i think the reason that happens
eventually someone will step up and
suggest an actual restaurant
but i think that happens because one
people might not want to take the
responsibility of choosing the
restaurant but i think also people are
afraid that if they pick a restaurant
and the rest of the group doesn't end up
liking the food that they're somehow
responsible for that so it is an
avoiding responsibility technique talk
to me a little bit about how tone plays
out in question asking tone is really
important tone can turn a question
negative or positive the same question
all right matt let's do a role play okay
i'm ready you ready okay so
you're gonna be the employee
and i'm gonna be the manager see how i
did that
yes ma'am all right so matt this is your
line and i will respond two ways you'll
say the line i'll respond you'll say the
line i'll respond again
your line is i have a plan to automate
customer service
all right
i have a plan to automate customer
service
what do you think it will take to
implement that plan all right generally
supportive
just say it again
i have a plan to automate customer
service what do you think it'll take to
implement that plan oh wow that's very
different
just emphasize one word that and it
changed the entire tone and context of
the meaning so your point deborah is
very clear tone really does matter in
question asking and and i would argue in
in most communication
having this conversation with you has
helped me realize that we can get better
answers if we ask better questions
so what goes into a good question i like
to use words that are related to values
words like
impact
an example would be matt
how does your decision
impact yourself and the organization
mm-hmm yeah
something like matt what's important or
what's at stake
and one that i love is say it's at the
end of a project
and i'll say to you matt
what can we create from here
and that just assumes that people are
creative
and once that's assumed that people rise
to the occasion and they free themselves
to make suggestions they might not
otherwise make
i really like that i i like positioning
the person uh in the conversation in a
very different perspective through the
question that you ask oh can i add one
more thing you sure can when the project
is over people often forget to ask
questions that will get a catalog of
what went well
what skills did you use to succeed how
did your team accomplish the task so
when it's all said and done you got the
project make sure you ask what went well
i love your list of questions it's about
open questions not clothes questions
it's about
asking people to reflect and really
think about the experience they had what
it felt like what they learned from it
how they can apply it thinking about
impactful words you like how i did that
i used one of your impactful words
and then well done and then making sure
that you ask questions about when a
project is complete that that that's a
fantastic advice for for
good questions to ask
speaking of advice
what advice would you give to business
leaders regarding question asking
whether you're a leader or anywhere in
the organization
it takes a bravery to ask questions if
you don't know what the answer will be
as adults it's scary kids ask a lot of
questions yes they do
what color is the moon and when's dinner
but adults don't ask as many questions
because it's a little scary
you're handing the control of the
conversation to someone else
and you have this fear that it could
harm your psyche
in summary my advice is to
leave time for questions and be open to
the answers ones that you want to hear
or answers that you don't want to hear
and then assess how much meeting time
you spend asking
versus telling people what to do so
inquiry versus statements
that last uh point about uh speaking
time and and how they're allocated
versus inquiry or statements we've heard
that before when bob sutton was on the
podcast we spent a little bit about it
and and he said from his perspective in
his research he's found that leaders who
ask more questions
are perceived as better leaders have
better data to make decisions and
actually people like them more so
there's a whole lot of value to
following the advice of making sure to
leave time for questions
be opening to be open to the answers and
then pay attention to how much time
you're you're asking actually asking
questions versus uh just making
statements so thank you for that really
important advice
now you've done a lot of question asking
throughout your life as a reporter as a
coach and a teacher what are some best
practices for question asking and does
the context matter
yes the context definitely matters you
have to know who's in the room
what their agendas are what their needs
are so that's something you have to
figure out before you figure out the
question or even the type of question
you want to ask
in terms of best practices
i'll frame it this way i feel like a lot
of best practices
stem from a mindset of curiosity
so if i were interviewing you matt but
this is not just for interviewing but if
i were an npr reporter like i was
interviewing you
and you say something that surprises me
or has emotional charge i'm going to
follow up on that and ask you another
question
sure i've come with my list of 10
questions to ask you those questions but
i don't have to stick to that script
i can just go off script and come back
what i do as a journalist is i have my
list but i say in advance
these three questions i absolutely need
answers to but the rest if i hear
something interesting i go for it
that's really really interesting so if
you take time to listen thoroughly and
ask questions you can actually learn a
lot more information when you think
about being curious you're listening for
information that's interesting and
surprising but you're also in a state
where you're curious about the other
person
and you're not just asking them
questions from your own frame of
reference
matt if i were interviewing you
who would want to do questions
that delight or engage you or questions
they may not have thought about before
so
here's an example
i was at my brother's house and he had a
friend over who was a physicist he
worked at uc berkeley as a postdoc so i
thought oh i'm interested in physics but
i don't know much but i know something
i'll ask him the question that i know
so i said are you a theoretical
physicist or an applied physicist
he answered the question it was okay
question
but he didn't get very excited about it
so then i thought for a minute and i
asked him
what's something surprising that
happened for you this year
and suddenly he lit up he got so
animated he was talking about these
things that he had done in his lab and
he was picking up things on the table
like a cup or a plate and showing me how
mass works by using these the cup and
the and the plate and so at the end i
found out that he discovered something
pretty cool it was
connecting mathematics to a particle
that scientists think is related to dark
matter so of course i can't understand
the full scope of what that means not
being a physicist but
it was pretty amazing and if i hadn't
asked that question it that never would
have happened
wow so again it's it's being curious and
and really thinking about how to help
how to put the other person in position
where they can can share an answer
that's really meaningful for them
yeah and i would say this is good for
leaders as well
when you ask someone a question
ask them a question that enables them to
speak from their perspective
so ask those open questions give them a
chance to speak from their base of
knowledge and not what they think you
want them to say based on your frame of
knowledge uh excellent way to summarize
that
let me ask you this do you have a secret
weapon or trick up your sleeve that you
use to get to insightful and
surprising responses
i do
i call it the killer last question
tell me more
and i'll have to tell you what it is and
how you ask it that's a very important
part there's several steps
i'm talking with someone and we've had a
conversation we've built rapport and
it's time to end the conversation or the
interview
so i say to them
is there anything i didn't ask you that
you think is important
and then here's the next step and this
is really important
i had to wait
i had to wait in silence and be
comfortable with the silence
and then
nine out of 10 times the person says
i don't think so
but then you wait again
another it could be like eight seconds
[Music]
and then they will say the most
interesting thing
that they said in the whole interview
and i think this happens because you are
turning the control over to them
you're handing them the mic you are
putting them in the driver's seat and so
it creates a condition where they're
more likely to share something or at the
end of this conversation we've been
talking about a lot of things
it lets them ask a question of
themselves
and get you an answer so something
they're excited about
you know it's interesting that you bring
that technique up of waiting because uh
waiting is something i always coach
people to do people don't like that
awkward pause so they'll ask a question
and if nobody responds immediately then
they'll just move on
right i had never really thought of that
pause
allowing people to really do some
self-reflection
and really having
that be an opportunity for people to to
dig deeper and provide
more information or disclose something
that's that's a little more personal so
i i really like that let's do an
experiment for our listeners
i'm gonna ask you a question that you've
never heard right you don't know what
i'm gonna say i have no idea i'm locked
in this cone of silence and then
ask it to you once and then i'll ask it
in a different way and see how the
results change
all right so i'm going to answer it
twice go for it yes here's the first
question
today's podcast will be really great
right
absolutely this should be a great
podcast
let me ask in a different way
what is important to you about today's
podcast
i
so much hope that people listen to your
passion for asking questions to really
bond and build on relationships people
have that i hope when people are done
listening that they feel they have
the tools and the energy to go do what
you do
so those are the two questions so you
can see the difference the first
question the way i asked it i didn't get
any information
um and then did you feel a little bit
pigeonholed like there was only one one
there really was only one answer what am
i gonna say
to that right
totally but the second question really
allowed me to to give insight into the
the work that i did and you did in
preparation for this and really let
people know that we really want people
to take good value from what it is we do
so i totally appreciate the difference
and i can see why you are a good
question asker so so thank you for that
now this whole
time we've talked today deborah has been
about questions and answering would you
indulge me
and answer the three questions that i
ask of all of our guests at the end of
our podcast
absolutely if you listen to the answers
i'll tell you anything
i will absolutely listen question number
one if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would that be
be present and build on others ideas
this is the improv wisdom that's come
down
decades and decades to
me today and to the people i'm teaching
excellent thank you
let me ask you question number two who
is a communicator that you admire and
why
i'm really interested by kamala harris
right now
she is very calm
at the same time she's very passionate
it's a great combination
and she owns the room
a lot of politicians are very stiff
she's not she moves but she moves with
purpose so when she moves there's a
reason and it's very clear
and the last thing about her is that she
has mastered the smile for all occasions
she has the right smile for whether
she's debating mike pence or
introducing joe biden she has a right
smile and smiling can be really tricky
for women
tell me more about smiling in in the the
challenges involved in that
i've seen a lot of women be given the
communication advice to smile
and i think it's really undermining
because
we know what we want to say and how we
want to say it
and if we're given the advice smile more
essentially we're being told to be nicer
to see more pleasant
to
even be more feminine
and those can be really undermining
messages and i see it all the time so
sometimes as a woman it's hard to
remember that you own your smile you own
your presentation and that you should do
what's best for you
absolutely absolutely
let me ask question number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
i'm going to go back to again be present
and i'll tell you a little bit more
about why
it keeps you grounded it connects you to
your audience of one or a thousand
and it keeps that inner critic that
judge
away from you we all have that critic
that right now say
i'm talking to you
i am thinking about what i said just a
minute ago and judging it was that
stupid and then right now i'm talking to
you and i might if i had a judge i might
be judging myself what i'm saying right
now is stupid and then we'll move on to
the next question i'm not listening
because i'm thinking about the stupid
thing i said a moment ago
right a judge is really powerful
and if we can be present we can move
that judge out of the way
that's number one
[Music]
number two i would say
rigorously prepare
but be ready to go off script you need
both of those pieces you have you really
have to prepare i know you've said this
in the past also matt that there's no
substitute for preparation but you need
to be ready to go off script
lead with energy and commitment to the
audience if you do that you will engage
your audience they see that you want to
be there that you're excited to be there
and that you
are there for them 100
and when you do that it will give you
more confidence and confidence will
improve your credibility in front of
your audience
i really like your recipe a lot being
present and prepara preparing but being
willing to
to go with what's needed in the moment
really powerful and then of course being
audience-centric and and doing so in an
energetic way will help
you know deborah thank you so much
as we wrap up i find myself asking a
question
what are my takeaways from today and and
the answer is abundantly clear
questions can really help our
communication by taking the time to plan
our questions and actively listen to the
answers we can build camaraderie and
closeness and ultimately
improve our communication thank you so
much for your time and for your insight
it's been my pleasure
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart
the podcast a production of stanford
graduate school of business to learn
more go to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcasts
you